foreign
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and in this session we will try to
delete a row in SQL but before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple Technologies and if
you're a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply John now without further Ado
let's get started
how do you delete a row and SQL let's
quickly take a look at the syntax
so we will be using the delete keyboard
and the front keyword adding the table
name and giving a where Clause with a
user defined condition so this will be a
basic Syntax for the process of deleting
a single Row in the SQL table now to
understand in a much better way let's
get back to the SQL workbench so now we
are on the SQL workbench and previously
we tried to create table add some data
using the insert command and update a
value using the upgrade command now
let's say we have to delete the last row
which is 1006 Jeremy Hyderabad let's say
Jeremy found a new job in a new
organization and now you need to
eliminate his credentials from your
database so we will be using the
following code
that is delete
from table name as employee
table
and the weight loss
now the condition
which is
EMP ID
is equals to 1 0 0 6. now let's try to
run the code
there you go the employee is being
eliminated from that particular database
now let's try to recheck the table
so select
star from EMP
loyee
table
run the code and there you go the last
ID which was one zero zero six has been
eliminated from your database and that's
how you delete a row in SQL and with
that we have come to an end of the
session if you have any queries
regarding this session then please do
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be more
than happy to resolve all your queries
at the audience until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here